pourquoi dit on monte sur ses grands
chevaux si quelqu'un monte sur ses
grands chevaux pendant une discussion
cela signifie qu'il s'emporte qu'il
prend les autres de haut cette métaphore
est utilisé au moins depuis le 16e
siècle mais son origine est plus
ancienne elle vient de la place que le
cheval occupait dans une activité
majeure la guerre au moyen-âge sur les
champs de bataille les nobles chevaliers
domine l'infanterie ce sont eux les
combattants d'élite est grimpée sur leur
monture il se trouve plus haut que la
piétaille comme on l'appelle celle qui
va à pied du champ de bataille aux
joutes verbales vous l'avez compris il
n'y a qu'un pas on monte donc sur nos
grands chevaux dans une conversation
pour tenter de dominer l'autre